j'aimerais
attendu qu'on sait quoi ça tu reconnais
pas non c'est la médaille de champion
d'afrique
j'ai
l'habitude non mais comme ça j'en ai pas
connu non présent nettement pourtant
j'ai gagné tous les titres sur la scène
nationale donc liga coupe de la ligue
coupe de france j'ai fait deux
demi-finales ligue des champions une
finale mais la can c'est celle à cannes
en fait je pouvais même pas imaginer
vivre ça dans ma vie j'ai été choqué
choquée chevet
des émissions ouais ah oui tu représente
un pays sûr présente un peuple et on
sait on sait que le foot dans notre pays
le sénégal 10 vit différemment et donc
on savait que on se devait de ramener ça
à notre pays qui l'attendait depuis
longtemps et on voulait aussi être les
premiers à la soulever c'est chose faite
ouais ouais parce que quand tu commences
tu es jeune tout tombe dessus tu te
rends pas forcément compte de quels sont
les enjeux etc
après tu te rends compte que tu peux
être payés bien payés pour jouer au foot
tu peux mettre sa famille à l'abri donc
peut-être qu'à un moment donné tu coures
un petit peu après l'argent mais tu vois
que c'est pas le bon moteur et tu ne
cherches pas ce que tu es jeune mais
aujourd'hui j'ai compris pourquoi je
joue au foot et c'est pour ces émotions
là parce que je sais que en dehors du
foot c'est très très dur de réunir
autant de personnes pour une même cause
dans la joie et bonheur et ça ça a pas
plus
sur ce but cependant c'est le choix
qu'il y avait un million de personnes
dans les rues on s'entendait pas en
habit 7 heures pour faire une quinzaine
de kilomètres est arrivé au palais on
arrive à 2 heures du matin au lieu de
début de soirée mais c'est exceptionnel
j'ai passé sept heures sur le toit d'un
bus avec des millions de personnes qui
nous acclame danser c'était grandiose le
reste est grandiose réalise à peine en
réalité parce que au final des gens
normaux quand vous gagnez certes une
compétition mais on est comme ceux qui
nous acclame mais la seule différence
c'est qu'on on était sur le terrain et
on a on a donné ce plaisir au peuple et
non le rendu en famille
capitaine des espoirs de soulèverait la
can avec au sénégal leur ai dit quoi je
me serais dit ça va vite ça va très vite
mais pourquoi pas parce que j'ai
toujours voulu découvrir mon pays
jamais eu le temps à cause d'eux à cause
du foot et de ma carrière mais dès que
dès que je les fais ça a été ça a été
une révélation et il y avait plus de
doute on a choisi de représenter le
sénégal niveau de france ça a été le
déclic j'ai raté l'euro espoirs et c'est
la première fois que j'avais de réelles
vacances en réalité parce que parce que
tout le temps j'étais j'étais
sélectionné des u16 a eu 21 et donc
j'avais jamais le temps de poser là j'ai
raté l'euro espoirs ça m'a permis de me
dire ou es ce que voit ce qu'on va avec
ma femme et on s'est décidé à radio
sénégal c'était ma première j'ai pu le
faire incognito parce qu'ils suivent pas
beaucoup le foot allemand la voix donc
je l'adoré nice mais personne ne le
reconnaissez et puis des clic déclic
déclic
le choix parce que la sélection et c'est
des drags et après ça je pense que
c'est une question beaucoup plus vaste
que ça on ne peut pas répondre juste
parce qu'il ya autant d'histoires que
des binationaux chacun a son parcours
chacun son d'éducation chacun sa famille
chacun a son background et
c'est trop c'est trop réducteur de le
réduire à à il est mû par dépit à wall-e
nu pour telle ou telle chose chacun son
parcours moi j'ai eu bien et je pense
que chacun d'eux va avoir le temps et le
droit de faire son parcours avant de se
décider mais une fois décidée qui
viennent avec conviction avec envie et
pour les bonnes raisons c'était presque
visionnaire
visionnaire je ne sais pas parce que
c'est un choix réfléchi rivalité mais
notre cas je le regrette pas je pense
que c'est le meilleur choix de carrière
que j'ai fait
jusque là le sénégal ça représentait
quoi le pays de mon père il y avait
aussi beaucoup de mythes et de fantasmes
autour parce que c'était un petit peu
l'inconnu avant que j'y aille et depuis
que j y suis c'est ma terre tout
simplement